denis perrault secrétaire national de la
confédération paysanne
bonsoir denis perreault on rappelle ce
chiffre un bonsoir et merci surtout
d'être avec nous on rappelle ce chiffre
en hausse de la consommation de la
viande 18% ça aurait pu être une
excellente nouvelle pour vous mais ça ne
l'est pas vraiment on imagine votre
déception oui bonsoir oui évidemment on
est forcément déçu on constate que non
seulement le marché une autre mais les
prix à la consommation augmente aussi
et pendant ce temps les industriels les
marchands l'innovateur il continue de
faire pression sur les prix et il me
manque quelques amis et bien en dessous
des coûts de production donc on a décidé
de s'associer à la des ratios nationale
bovine sur ce sujet là pour faire de la
rétention ouvrés pour obliger le
gouvernement à ces et à s'impliquer dans
ces dossiers là et tordre le bras ou aux
industriels pour une meilleure
répartition de la marge et pour qu'on
arrive à un prix rémunérateur justement
denis perron avant d'aller plus loin
c'est important pour les téléspectateurs
qui nous regardent effectivement on a
tous sincèrement je le dis franchement
sur ce plateau constater ces hausses de
prix dans les supermarchés
vous vous dites voilà vous venez pas
vous n'êtes pas payé en fonction où va
l'argent
mais c'est une bonne question ni prix
sont un peu discuté on a trop soft est
restée cachée ou l'heure c'est le fut
inégal que ce soit sur les prix et
une quantité tout ça est manifestement
c'est sûr c'est ça qui progresse le plus
parce qu'ils veulent et on doit être
plus 60 et en freinant lloyd à +38 de
cuisson son cas et c'est vraiment sur le
steak haché qui a à priori plus de
d'obscurantisme d'obscurité tout au
moins sur les la répartition des marges
donc on va nous dire qu'il ya quelques
problèmes de logistique
effectivement il ya peut-être un peu
moins de camions il ya un peu moins de
monde dans les abattoirs
s'il ya des salariés qui gardent leurs
gamins où ils font valoir leur droit de
retrait mais globalement
on se demande où passe l'argent aussi
donc vous vous adaptez clairement au
gouvernement pour qu'il fasse pression
est ce que le gouvernement réellement
une marge de manoeuvre connan il ya deux
ans soit ou non il ya eu les états
généraux de l'agriculture dont le but de
la manoeuvre était de répartir la marge
est de trouver les prix de revient les
coûts de production et tout ça pour que
la marge et russell fils d'agriculteur
l'état des courses les coûts de
production bien été calculé mais au lieu
de fixer les primes d'imposer quelque
chose
le gouvernement a dit ça serait bien de
répartir la valeur un petit peu plus
équitablement
donc vous comprenez bien que sur une
simple suggestion celui dont il n'y voit
pas de bon coeur elle n'y voit pas
naturellement
merci beaucoup en tout cas denis
perrault secrétaire national
confédération paysanne de vous être
exprimé en direct sur rt france